This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When somebody gets in a car wreck, there's a group of people who rush to the scene to examine exactly what happened. Is Derni accident's working right now, Joe? They're called. Police officers. We can talk about reports and this and that, but maybe we can go right out. This is New York State Trooper Frank Bandiro.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。当有人发生车祸时，会有一群人赶到现场，确切地调查到底发生了什么。乔，德尼事故处理组现在在工作吗？他们被称为警察。我们可以谈论报告之类的东西，但也许我们可以直接去现场。这是纽约州警官弗兰克·班迪罗。
And writing Shotgun with Bandiro is Stan Alcorn from the investigative reporting podcast Reveal. I went for this ride along last spring. Not so much to see a wreck as to see the paperwork. Oh and something else I want to show you. Our accident reporter is right here. In the past 50 years, the car crash death rate has fallen by nearly 80 percent, and one of the reasons for that drop has to do with this accident report form. It's where Bandiro writes down the weather, draws a diagram of the wreck, identifies its primary cause. So you've got like a whole list of possible causes.
和班迪罗一起坐在副驾驶座上的是来自调查报道播客《揭秘》的斯坦·奥尔科恩。去年春天我参加了这次随警巡逻。与其说是为了看车祸，不如说是为了看文书工作。哦，还有别的东西我想给你看。我们的事故报告员就在这里。在过去的50年里，车祸死亡率下降了近80%，而下降的原因之一与这份事故报告表有关。班迪罗在这里写下天气，画出事故示意图，并确定其主要原因。所以你有一整套可能的原因列表。
Oh yeah. I don't know if you can read those little things, but there's a million. I mean, try to cover all the basic. Okay, so we're gonna call the base- The eight there. Animal action can go- Exactly. Say a deer is crossing a roadway. I try to tell my wife that the safest thing to do is to slow down as much as you can without being unsafe and drive straight through the animal. Really? Yes. As we join the Long Island commuters on the southern state parkway, a call comes in over
哦，是的。我不知道你能不能读懂那些小字，但有上百万个。我的意思是，尽量涵盖所有基本情况。好吧，我们要把基础……那里的八号。动物行为可以……没错。假设有一只鹿正在穿过马路。我试着告诉我的妻子，最安全的做法是在不造成危险的情况下尽可能减速，然后直接从动物身上开过去。真的吗？是的。当我们加入长岛通勤者在南部州际公路上的行列时，电台里传来了一个电话。
the radio. This turned out to be just a fender bender, but if it were one of the more than 30,000 fatal car accidents that happened each year. I'd stay in here for now. The information gathered on the side of the road would go from that accident report form into a federal database. The fatality analysis reporting system. Anyone can use this database.
这只是一个小擦碰，但如果它是每年发生的3万多起致命车祸中的一起呢。我现在就待在这里。在路边收集的信息将从那份事故报告表进入联邦数据库。死亡分析报告系统。任何人都可以使用这个数据库。
In car companies, safety advocates and regulators are combing through it constantly, looking for patterns that help them understand how and why people combing through it constantly, looking for patterns that help them understand how and why people die in car wrecks. Which then helps designers and engineers create safer vehicles and roadways. The data informs all kinds of design decisions around car safety. Everything from speed limits to mandatory seat belts. But this culture of heavily regulated data-driven
在汽车公司，安全倡导者和监管机构不断地梳理它，寻找有助于他们了解人们如何在车祸中死亡的模式。这反过来又帮助设计师和工程师制造更安全的车辆和道路。这些数据为围绕汽车安全的所有设计决策提供了依据。从限速到强制安全带，应有尽有。但这种高度监管的数据驱动的汽车安全工程文化，并不总是存在的。事实上，起初，汽车制造商试图将车祸数据据为己有。他们不仅抵制让汽车更安全，还辩称制造安全汽车的想法是不可能的。这个故事始于20世纪初。当时汽车广告不谈论安全功能，而是谈论造型。从其新款飞行翼式后挡泥板的轻快风格，一直到其大胆而优雅的新前部造型，
auto-safety engineering, it did not always exist. In fact, at first, automakers tried to keep data about car wrecks to themselves. They not only resisted making cars safer, they argued the very idea of a safe car was impossible. The story starts in the early 20th century. When car ads didn't talk about their safety features, they talked about styling. From the rakeish flair of its new flight swept rear fenders, right up to its bold but elegant new front styling,
新款动力风格克莱斯勒强调了运动中力量的前瞻性。看起来它还在移动。即使在它停下来的时候，也是一种设计。一位克莱斯勒安全总监实际上把汽车比作女人的帽子，说“它们必须具有特殊的吸引力，有时甚至会牺牲功能”。
the new power style Chrysler emphasizes the forward look of power in motion. Looks like it's still moving. Even when it stops, some design. A Chrysler safety director actually compared cars to women's hats, saying that, quote, they have to have special attractiveness, and sometimes they even compromise with function.
当讨论安全时，谈论的不是汽车。而是关于驾驶员。不幸的是，我们中间有一些驾驶员是糟糕的体育运动员。在第一起已知的致命车祸发生后的25年内，汽车已成为美国意外死亡的主要原因。但所有这些死亡都被归咎于“方向盘后的疯子”。他们是造成事故、导致伤亡的破坏者。换句话说，汽车不会杀人。人杀人。
When safety was discussed, it wasn't about the car. It was about the driver. Unfortunately, there are drivers amongst us who are poor sports. Within 25 years of the first known fatal car crash, automobiles had become the leading cause of accidental death in the U.S. But all those deaths were blamed on the, quote, nut behind the wheel. They are the wreckers who caused the accidents that may and kill. In other words, cars don't kill people. People kill people.
整个机器可能会对你从车祸中幸存的可能性产生某种影响的概念，在20世纪上半叶甚至都没有出现在人们的视野中。这是艾米·冈格洛夫，一位研究汽车安全的历史学家。从安全的角度来看，你会如何描述当时的汽车，并将它们与今天的汽车进行比较？20世纪。这是艾米·冈格洛夫，一位研究汽车安全的历史学家。从安全的角度来看，你会如何描述当时的汽车，并将它们与今天的汽车进行比较？嗯，在很大程度上，它们是死亡陷阱。忘了安全带和安全气囊吧。第一批汽车的挡风玻璃是用普通的平板玻璃制成的。
The whole notion that the machine could have some sort of impact on the likelihood of you surviving a car crash wasn't even on the radar during the first half of the 20th century. This is Amy Gangloff, a historian whose studies auto safety. Safety wise, how would you characterize the cars then and compare them to the cars of today? the 20th century. This is Amy Gangloff, a historian who studies auto safety. Safety wise, how would you characterize the cars then and compare them to the cars of today? Um, in large part they were death traps. Forget seat belts and airbags. The first cars had windshields made out of regular old plate glass.
如果你的头穿过它，你可能会被刺入脖子的玻璃碎片卡住。但在有人能想出更安全的汽车之前，必须有人先提出汽车可以更安全的想法。冈格洛夫将这个想法追溯到一位名叫休·德黑文的自学成才的科学家身上。你告诉我它是怎么做的。这是一盘我找到的德黑文接受采访的旧磁带。这个项目实际上始于1917年和1918年，当时我正在飞行……
If your head went through it, you could get stuck with shards of glass pressing into your neck. But before someone could come up with a safer car, someone had to come up with the idea that cars could be safer. Gangloff traces that idea to a self-taught scientist named Hugh De Haven. You tell me how it's done. This is an old cassette tape I tracked down of De Haven being interviewed. The project really started in 1917 and 18 when I was flying through our flying floor.
那是第一次世界大战期间的加拿大空军。当他距离被任命仅剩24小时时，他发生了一场可怕的飞机事故。我肝脏破裂了。我胰腺破裂了。很好。我胰腺破裂了，我胆囊破裂了，很好，我肾脏破裂了。当他在医院时，他有了某种顿悟的时刻。
That's the Canadian Air Force in World War I. When he was just like 24 hours away from being commissioned, he had a horrific plane accident. I ruptured my liver. I ruptured my pang trance. I ruptured my gall bladder. Good. I ruptured my pankance, I ruptured my gallbladder, good, I ruptured my kidneys. While he was in the hospital, he had his kind of moment of his epiphany.
我头部受伤时没有失去知觉，但我确实有这些腹部损伤。他得出结论，他的安全带上有一个尖锐的旋钮，这很可能导致了他的受伤。于是他开始思考，也许我们可以更好地包装人类。不仅是在飞机上，在汽车里也是如此。德黑文从碰撞测试物体开始，将鸡蛋从越来越高的高度扔到衬垫上。
I had no loss of consciousness around head injury, but I did have these abdominal injuries. He concluded that there was a sharp knob on his safety belt that had probably led to his injuries. And so he started thinking that perhaps we can package human beings better. Not just in airplanes, but also in cars. The Haven started by crash testing objects, dropping eggs onto padding from higher and higher heights.
他发现一个鸡蛋如果落在三英寸厚的橡胶垫上，可以从100英尺高的地方坠落而幸存。然后他转向人类，追踪那些出现在真实报纸头条背后的人，比如“女孩从10层楼坠落，幸存并讲述了经过”。他了解到我们就像鸡蛋一样。如果冲击力在时间和空间上分散开来，我们可以在看似无法幸存的碰撞中幸存下来。就像当你掉进松软的泥土里，或者被甩进安全带而不是撞上挡风玻璃时。最后，他转向了在最高频的高速碰撞源中人们身体上到底发生了什么。汽车。为了做到这一点，他打电话给医院、验尸官和警察，他们中的大多数人都认为他疯了。
He found an egg could survive a 100 foot fall if it landed on a three-inch thick rubber mat. Then he turned to human beings, tracking down the people behind actual newspaper headlines, like, girl falls 10 stories, lives, and tells of it. And he learned that we are just like eggs. We can survive seemingly unsurvivable collisions, if the impact is spread out over time and space. Like when you fall into soft dirt or get thrown into a seat belt instead of the windshield. Finally, he turned to what was actually happening to people's bodies in the most prolific source of high-speed collisions. Cars. To do that, he called up hospitals, corners, and police officers, most of whom thought he was nuts.
为什么这个想法会如此疯狂？这是一个疯狂的，实际上这是一个非常简单的事情。那时候的人和直到今天的人都觉得，如果你发生车祸，你就会受伤。当你没有在车祸中幸存时，你看，这就是所谓的“耶稣因素”。你无法计算它。德黑文疯狂的理论是，人们在车祸中身体发生的事情不仅仅是运气。这不是你无法计算或改变的事情。这是汽车设计的一个可预测的产物。现在这看起来如此常识，以至于很难察觉，
Why would the thought of be so nutty? It's a crazy, well actually it's a very simple thing. People in those days and people through this day feel, if you get in a crash, you're going to get hurt. When you're not avert in a crash, you look, it's what they call the Jesus factor. You can't calculate it. The Haven's crazy theory was that what happened to people's bodies in a car crash was not just luck. It wasn't something you couldn't calculate or change. It was a predictable product of the car's design. It seems so common sense now, it's hard to even register it,
但在当时，这是革命性的。在40年代和50年代，德黑文证明了这是真的。1953年，他与印第安纳州警察局合作进行了一项为期一年的研究。通过他们的照片以及医生和验尸官的报告，他能够分离出汽车在碰撞中最危险的部分，而这些是我们现在甚至没有想到的东西，比如坚硬的无衬垫仪表板和带有锋利边缘的钢旋钮，它们会
but at the time, it was revolutionary. And in the 40s and 50s, to Haven would prove it was true. In 1953, he partnered with the Indiana State Police for a year-long study. And with their photos and reports from doctors and coroners, he was able to isolate which parts of the car were the most dangerous in a crash and there were things that we don't even think of now like hard unpadded dashboards and steel mobs with sharp edges that would
最终卡在人们的头骨里。是的，他正在诊断车内到底是什么导致了伤害。他发现了什么？他到底发现了什么导致了大多数这些伤害。转向柱，转向柱本身是不可折叠的。所以如果你发生正面碰撞，转向柱会向上推，甚至可能穿过某人的胸部，就像一根可能刺穿某人的长矛。解决方案是现在随处可见的可折叠转向柱，
end up stuck in people's skulls. Yeah he's diagnosing exactly what's causing the injuries inside the car. And what does he find? What exactly does he find is causing most of these injuries. The steering column, the steering column itself was not collapsible. So if you had a front end collision, the steering column would push up and might even push through somebody's chest, like a spear that might actually impale somebody. The solution was the now ubiquitous collapsible steering column,
根据一项政府研究，截至2012年，这项技术挽救了79,989人的生命。除了安全带，这比任何东西都多。但可折叠转向柱直到1967年才成为标准配置，距离德黑文的印第安纳研究结果发表已经过去了十多年，因为汽车公司根本不想处理他的发现。汽车公司对讨论安全问题非常偏执。在20世纪50年代，因为讨论安全问题几乎可以保证人们开始
a technology that saved 79,989 lives as of 2012, according to one government study. That's more than anything except the seat belts. But collapsible steering columns wouldn't become standard equipment until 1967, more than a decade after the results of De Haven's Indiana study were published, because car companies just did not want to deal with his findings. Car companies were very paranoid about having a discussion about safety. In the 1950s, because a discussion about safety was pretty much going to guarantee that people start
思考驾驶的危险。当你想到一个旋钮嵌入你的头骨或转向柱被塞进你的胸部时，开车就一点也不有趣了。我的意思是，你在这项研究中直接面对的事情之一就是我们的死亡率。而且，对风险的分析通常要求我们思考一些我们作为一个社会很少愿意去想的事情。但要让社会去思考这个问题，需要的不仅仅是学术研究。
thinking about the dangers of driving. And it's just not fun to drive when you're thinking about a knob getting embedded in your skull or a steering column being jammed into your chest. I mean, one of the things that you have in this definitely looking directly at is our mortality. And it's kind of the analysis of risks in general require us to think about something that is a society we rarely ever want to think about. But for society to think about it would take more than academic research.
它需要政治。你想知道我的名字以便记住我是谁吗？当然，我们这样做。你想说你是谁吗？这是琼·克莱布鲁克。琼·克莱布鲁克最终将负责美国的汽车安全，但在1965年，她还是一名政治新手，作为美国政治科学协会的研究员第一次来到华盛顿。
It would take politics. You want to have my name so you remember who I am? Sure we do that. You want to say who you are? This is Joan Claybrook. Joan Claybrook would eventually be in charge of auto safety for the United States, but in 1965 she was a political novice coming to Washington for the first time as a fellow for the American Political Science Association.
我报名与一位来自佐治亚州亚特兰大的国会议员一起工作，他担心他所在社区的孩子们在车祸中丧生。他读过《任何速度都不安全》。《任何速度都不安全》是一本由一位痴迷于汽车安全的年轻律师拉尔夫·纳德撰写的、不太可能的畅销书。所以我读了拉尔夫·纳德的书，那是第一次我意识到汽车设计对你在车祸中的生存至关重要。这本书采用了像休·德黑文这样的人的研究，并将其变成了一份对汽车行业的严厉
And I signed up to work with a member of Congress from Atlanta, Georgia, and he was concerned about the kids in his neighborhood being killed in car crashes. And he had read unsafe at any speed. Unsafe at any speed was an unlikely bestseller by a car safety obsessed young lawyer named Ralph Nader. So I read Ralph Nader's book and that was the first time that I realized that the car design was crucial in your survival and the car crash. The book took research by people like Hugh De Haven and turned it into a scorching
控诉。它显示汽车公司实际上已经为安全技术申请了专利，包括可折叠转向柱。他们只是没有使用它。我在这个时期认识了拉尔夫，因为我是他想做的所有事情中最愿意倾听的观众之一。在幕后，琼·克莱布鲁克与拉尔夫·纳德合作起草了一项首次监管汽车行业的法案。纳德会在国会面前作证，听起来像是一个研究生在阅读
indictment of the auto industry. It showed car companies had actually patented safety technology, including the collapsible steering column. They just weren't using it. I had gotten to know Rafa with this period because I was one of the most willing audiences for all the things he wanted to do. Behind the scenes, Joan Claybrook worked with Ralph Nader on a bill to regulate the auto industry for the first time. Nader would give testimony in front of Congress that sounded like a grad student reading
他过于学术的论文。为了增加点风味，这里有一些1967年的内容。我错过了他们为企业雇主服务的狂热活动。这些律师患上了一种隧道视野，随之而来的是一种被称为“聘用散光”的熟悉律师疾病。尽管听起来很无聊，但汽车行业对监管和纳德感到恐惧。这就是为什么汽车行业雇佣了一名私家侦探来跟踪纳德，获取一些关于他的黑料，并试图诋毁他。
his overly academic thesis paper. Just for flavor, here's some from 1967. I missed their frenetic activity to serve their corporate employers. These lawyers became afflicted with a tunnel vision that brings with it the familiar lawyer malady known as retainer astigmatism. Boring as that sounds, the auto industry was terrified of regulation and of nature. And that's why the auto industry hired a gum shoe to trail NATO and get some dirt on them and try and district credit them.
这是美国政治史上最伟大的自我毁灭行为之一。通用汽车没有在纳德身上找到任何东西，但消息传出去了，他们试图破坏他，这让通用汽车看起来非常糟糕。这就是他们所做的，也是让他成为民族英雄的原因。是的。他给了他很大的权力。在短短几个月内，汽车公司帮助激发了一场监管汽车公司的运动。而那场运动成功了。
This was one of the greatest self-owns in American political history. General Motors didn't get any turn on NATO, but word got out, they were trying to undermine him and it made General Motors look just terrible. And that's what they did and that's what made him a national hero. Yeah. He gave him a lot of power. In just a few months, the car companies had helped energize a movement to regulate car companies. And that movement succeeded.
我对国会和政府的成员以及朋友们表示敬意。1966年9月9日，林登·贝恩斯·约翰逊总统在白宫玫瑰园向200多名客人发表了讲话，其中包括拉尔夫·纳德和通用汽车总裁。他们听到的是一位总统用公共卫生的语言谈论汽车。多年来，我们一直容忍着一场肆虐的流行病。他称之为“公路病”，这种疾病杀死的美国人是
I was distinguished to members of the Congress and the administration and friends. On September 9, 1966, President Lyndon Baines Johnson addressed more than 200 guests at the White House Rose Garden, including Ralph Nader and the President of General Motors. What they heard was a president talking about cars in the language of public health. Our years now, we've tolerated a raging epidemic. He called it highway disease, a disease that had killed more than three times as many Americans
我们所有战争总和的三倍多，尽管我们有技术进步，但我们未能治愈它。在这个太空时代，我们获得了大量关于如何将人类送入太空以及如何将他们带回家的信息。然而，我们并不确定更多的汽车事故是由刹车故障、路肩松软、酒后驾驶还是鹿穿过公路引起的。就这样，LBJ开始签署法案。《交通安全法》将确保在发生事故时有更安全、保护更好的汽车。该法案创建了一个新的联邦机构，
as all our wars, and despite our technological advances, we were failing to cure it. In this age of space, we're getting plenty of information about how to send men into space and how to bring them home. Yet we don't know for certain whether more auto accidents are caused by faulty breaks or by soft shoulders or by drunk drivers or even by the deer crossing the highway. And with that, LBJ started signing bills. Traffic safety act will ensure safer, better protected cars in the event of an accident. That bill created a new federal agency,
也就是现在的国家公路交通安全管理局。它有权要求汽车公司安装安全带和可折叠转向柱，并建立那些碰撞数据库。如果这还不够，这项创建强大的政府机构来监管当时该国一些最大的公司的法案，
what's now the National Highway Traffic Safety Administration. It had the power to make car companies install seat belts and collapsible steering columns, and to set up those crash databases. And in case that wasn't enough, this bill to create a powerful government agency to regulate what were then some of the largest companies in the country,
以近乎一致的两党支持通过了。60年代是一个非常不同的时代。非常感谢，查武。60年代强制要求的技术，如安全带和可折叠转向柱，至今每年仍在挽救成千上万人的生命。但车祸死亡率在过去几十年里持续下降，部分原因是更小、更微妙的设计变化。
it passed with nearly unanimous bipartisan support. The 60s were a very different time. Thank you, Chavu, very much. The technologies that were mandated in the 1960s, like seat belts and collapsible steering columns, are still saving thousands of lives each year. But the car crash death rate has continued to drop decade after decade, in part because of smaller, subtler design changes.
要了解这些变化是如何发生的，你必须回到政府的车祸数据库。那些由像弗兰克·班迪罗这样的警察提供信息，并由像马特·布鲁姆博洛这样的安全工程师使用的数据库。马特·布鲁姆博洛是公路安全保险协会（IIHS）的一名工程师。在他的桌子上，他既有一个汽车前灯，又有一本巨大的联邦法规纸质书。这是在阅读联邦公报。是的。这是我的有趣消遣。
And to understand how those changes happen, you have to go back to the government databases of car crashes. The ones fed by police officers like Frank Bandero and used by safety engineers like Matt Brumbolo. Matt Brumbolo is an engineer at the Insurance Institute for Highway Safety or IHS. On his desk he has both a car headlight and a giant paper book of federal regulations. It's reading the federal register. Yeah. It's my fun pastime.
大约10年前，马特正在查看那个政府的致命车祸数据库。等等，政府运营的网站。在梳理数据时，他注意到了一些事情。在正面碰撞测试中被评为安全的汽车中，人们在正面碰撞中死亡。许多这些碰撞都有一个独特的特征。乘客侧还可以，但驾驶员侧看起来就像一个巨人用槌球槌摧毁了汽车的角落，将保险杠推过了发动机。车轮通常要么完全脱落，要么被推回乘员空间。是花了一些时间才识别出来，还是像立即就发现了？
About 10 years ago, Matt was looking at that government database of fatal crashes. And waited, government ran website. Sifting through the data, he noticed something. People dying in head-on crashes in cars that were rated safe in head-on crash tests. A lot of these crashes had a distinctive look. The passenger side was okay, but the driver's side looked like a giant had destroyed the corner of the car with a croquet melt, pushing the bumper past the engine. And the wheel is often pushed either completely off or pushed way back towards the occupant space. Did it take some time to recognize or was it like immediate?
相当立即。他立即意识到这是一种这些本应安全的汽车根本没有设计去承受的碰撞，这对马特来说是一个机会。我们可能可以对此做点什么。比如设计一个新的碰撞测试。IIHS自2012年以来一直在进行这项测试。我参加了宝马X1的其中一次碰撞测试。在主活动开始前的几个小时里，这有点像我想象中的后台
It's fairly immediate. He immediately recognized that this was a kind of crash these otherwise safeguards just hadn't been designed to withstand, which to Matt was an opportunity. We can probably do something about it. Something like designing a new crash test. The test IHS has been doing since 2012. I went one of these crash tests for the BMW X1. And in the hours before the main event, it's kind of how I imagine it would be backstage
在演出前，有一群人跑来跑去，对明星进行微小的化妆调整。除了明星是一辆紧凑型SUV，而且没有头发和化妆，只有传感器和仪器。在房间的一个角落里，宝马的工程师们挤在一起。他们在这里基本上只是为了确保他们做的一切都是对的吗？不，他们总是做对一切。不，只是你。但密切关注，因为宝马在这方面投入巨大，之前的型号在这个测试中获得了边缘评级，
before a show with a team of people running around, making tiny cosmetic tweaks to the star. Except the star is a compact SUV and instead of hair and makeup, there are sensors and instruments. And huddled in one corner of the room, engineers from BMW. It's here basically here just to make sure they're doing everything right? No, they're doing always everything right. No, just but you. But watching closely, because BMW has a lot riding on this, an earlier model got a marginal rating on this test,
比可接受低一级。所以宝马重新设计了汽车。它总是为新要求而设计。所以如果你有来自IIHS的新要求，我们必须重新设计我们的汽车。汽车在这些测试中的表现对购车者很重要，因此对汽车制造商也很重要。如今，安全可以销售，并且
one step below acceptable. So BMW redesigned the car. It's always designed for the new requirements. So if you have a new requirement from the IHS, we have to redesign our car. How cars do in these tests matters to car buyers, and so it matters to car makers. These days, safety sells, and it
证明了一个极其严格的技术过程。你现在在做什么？放置安全带传感器胶带，所以它是沿着这些杆读取并告诉我们安全带运动的胶带。这是泰勒·艾尔斯，假人工程师。这辆车里现在有多少个传感器？现在至少对于我的假人来说总共有39个。测量碰撞测试假人的位置，精确到毫米。二，六，六。他用手指给假人的脸涂上一半粉色一半蓝色，这样我们就能看到它撞击安全气囊的位置。
justifies an incredibly rigorous technical process. What are you doing right now? Putting the seat belt sensor tape so it's tape that reads along these bars and tells us the movement of the seat belt. This is Tyler Ayers, dummy engineer. How many sensors are in this car right now? Right now at least for my dummy is 39 total.ar measures the crash test dummy's position down to the millimeter. Two, six, six. And he finger paints the dummy's face half pink half blue so we can see where it hits the airbags.
那很好。有点。是的，差不多。我说我离开这里后得去马戏团跳跃，画小丑脸。我们走了，对吧？让我们走出这里。当我们走进有回声的碰撞大厅时，感觉不仅仅是一次汽车测试。感觉就像我在观看整个汽车安全循环的运作。
That's fine. Kind of. Yeah, pretty much. I said I got to jump at the circus after I leave here, painting clown faces. We're gone, right? Let's walk out of here. When we walk into the echoey crash hall, it feels like more than just a test of a car. It feels like I'm watching the whole cycle of auto safety in action.
你有新的和改进的重新设计X1，你有这种细致的数据驱动评估。39个传感器每秒发送10,000个样本。在将X1拖到每小时40英里的速度所需的17秒内。摧毁这辆车，希望它的下一个化身能更安全。几个月后，评级公布了。X1从边缘变为良好，并被评为IIHS顶级安全选择。这种变化始于安全工程师马特·布鲁姆博洛，他通过查看政府碰撞数据发现了
You've got the new and improved redesign X1, and you've got this meticulous data-driven evaluation. 39 sensors sending out 10,000 samples a second. For the 17 seconds, it takes to drag the X1 up to a speed of 40 miles per hour. Destroying this car in the hopes that maybe its next incarnation can be even safer. A couple months later, the rating would be announced. The X1 went from marginal to good, and it was named an IIHS top safety pick. And this change started with Matt Brumbleau, the safety engineer, who found a need for
一种新型碰撞测试的需求。那么，在做你所做的工作方面，这些现实世界车祸的联邦数据库有多重要？是的，它们确实不可或缺。没有真实的碰撞数据，我们只是在猜测。几年前，疾病控制中心发布了一份20世纪最伟大的公共卫生成就清单。清单上有疫苗、氟化水和机动车安全。
a new kind of crash test by going through government crash data. Well, in terms of doing the work that you do, how important are these federal databases of real-world car crashes? Yeah, they're really indispensable. Without real crash data, We are just be guessing. Few years back, the Centers for Disease Control put out a list of the greatest public health achievements of the 20th century. On the list are vaccines, Florida-Dated Water, and Motor Vehicle Safety.
几十年来，汽车越来越安全，因为监管机构、活动家和汽车工程师不断观察驾驶员是如何受伤的，并发现更多可以改进的地方。这是一个永无止境的过程，总是从数据开始。但这不是一个普遍的过程，并没有在所有行业发生。虽然自60年代以来，车祸死亡的几率下降了80%，但死于枪支的几率实际上上升了。当你听这些的时候，也许你一直在将汽车安全和枪支安全进行比较。如果是这样，你并不孤单。当专家们聚在一起谈论最新的大规模枪击事件时，
Decade after decade, cars keep getting safer, because regulators, activists, and the automobile engineers keep looking at how drivers get hurt and finding more things to improve. It's a never-ending process that always begins with data. But it is not a universal process that hasn't happened in all industries. While the odds of dying in a car crash have dropped by 80% since the 60s, the odds of dying from a firearm have actually gone up. As you've been listening to this, maybe you've been drawing parallels between car safety and gun safety. If so, you wouldn't be alone. When pundits get together to talk about the latest mass shooting,
你看到圣巴巴拉、桑迪胡克、弗吉尼亚理工、科伦拜恩，名单越来越长。有人经常提起它。这是一个有趣的类比，实际上非常能说明问题。弗吉尼亚理工、科伦拜恩，名单越来越长。有人经常提起它。这是一个有趣的类比，实际上非常能说明问题。法律专家迈克尔·沃尔德曼。你知道，我们影响了谁可以开车，我们将饮酒年龄提高到21岁，这样人们就不会鲁莽驾驶。我们安装了安全气囊，我们改变了汽车设计。
you see Santa Barbara Sandy Hook, Virginia Tech, Columbine, the list grows. Somebody often brings it up. It's an interesting analogy that's actually quite telling. Virginia Tech Columbine, the list grows. Somebody often brings it up. It's an interesting analogy and it's actually quite telling. Legal expert Michael Waldman. You know, we affected who could drive, we lifted the drinking age to 21 for, so people wouldn't drive recklessly. We put in airbags, we changed car design.
换句话说，我们改变了汽车并使它们更安全。而且，你知道，问题是，有没有办法用枪支也这样做？其他专家会正确地指出，汽车和枪支是非常不同的。一个是设计用来帮助一个人从A点到达B点，而另一个是专门设计用来伤害或杀人的。但公共卫生领域的人，这有点离题了。枪支是死亡和伤害的主要原因。无论这些死亡和伤害是否是故意的，研究人员都想知道
In other words, we changed cars and made them safer. And, you know, the question is, are there ways to do that also with guns? Other pundits will rightly make the point that cars and guns are very different. One is designed to help a person get from point A to point B, and the other is specifically designed to injure or kill. But people in the public health fields, that's kind of beside the point. Guns are a major cause of death and injury. And whether or not those deaths and injuries are intentional, researchers want to know whether
它们是否可以预防。他们想知道枪支设计或枪支所有权法律的改变，或者我们甚至还没有想到的其他技术，是否可以减少每年发生的2万多起枪支自杀和1万多起枪支他杀。一些专家认为，第一步可能是让枪支在研究方面更像汽车。例如，公共卫生教授斯蒂芬·特雷特呼吁创建一个目前不存在的东西。一个全面的死亡数据库，就像死亡分析报告系统，但针对枪支，包含关于受害者和肇事者的数据，无论他们是否在减少，
or not they're preventable. They want to know if a change in gun design or in laws about gun ownership, or some other technique we haven't even thought of yet, could cut down on the more than 20,000 gun suicides, and more than 10,000 gun homicides that happen each year. Some experts think the first step could be to treat guns more like cars when it comes to research. For example, public health professors Stephen Terrett has called for creating something that does not currently exist. A comprehensive database of deaths like the fatality analysis reporting system, but for guns with data about the victim and the perpetrator, whether they've been shrinking,
关于设备本身的细节。我们没有关于枪支死亡的这些数据，所以现在即使美国每年与机动车相关的死亡人数和枪支死亡人数大致相同。我们有其中一个的数据，我们没有另一个的数据。在80年代，特雷特使用政府碰撞数据来研究安全气囊和儿童约束法律，但随后他将注意力转向了枪支，差异非常明显。他不得不从验尸官和警察局收集自己的数据，而不是仅仅下载政府数据。
details about the device itself. We don't have those data with regard to gun deaths, so now even though the number of motor vehicle-related deaths and gun deaths in the United States are approximately the same every year. We have data for one, we don't have data for the other. In the 80s, Tarrat used government crash data to look at airbags and child restraint loss, but then he shifted his focus to guns, and the difference was stark. Instead of just downloading government data, he had to gather his own from coroners and police departments.
就像枪支安全的休·德黑文，只是晚了50年。这很难，很昂贵。而且有些信息，比如所用枪支的具体细节，他根本无法获得。围绕枪支已经形成了一种不收集信息的文化，而汽车方面的情况恰恰相反。如果你必须归纳一下，有没有一个大的因素可以解释这种差异？嗯，是的，有一个大的因素，
Like a gun safety hew to Haven, only 50 years later. It was hard, it was expensive. And some information, like specifics about the guns used, he just couldn't get. There's been a culture that's built up around guns of not collecting information, whereas the exact opposite has occurred with regard to cars. If you had to boil it down, is there one big thing to point to that explains that difference? Well, yes, there is one big thing,
和一个强大的因素可以指出。它被称为NRA，全国步枪协会。汽车安全史上的每一章，在枪支安全史上都有相反的一章，通常是在NRA的帮助下编写的，汽车安全的倡导者起诉汽车公司，枪支权利的倡导者使起诉枪支制造商几乎不可能。
and one powerful thing to point to. It's referred to as the NRA, the National Lifeholt Association. For every chapter in the history of auto safety, there's an opposite chapter in the history of gun safety, usually written with the help of the NRA, where advocates of auto safety, sued car companies, advocates of gun rights, made it nearly impossible to sue gun makers.
国会创建了一个驾驶员登记处，然后使创建枪支所有者登记处成为非法。对于联邦政府每年在汽车安全研究上花费的数亿美元，枪支暴力研究得到的只是几分钱。斯蒂芬·特雷特知道这一切。但在我交谈过的所有人中，他也是最乐观的，我觉得这有点难以理解。是什么让你仍然保持乐观，
Congress created a registry of drivers and then made it illegal to create a registry of gun owners. And for each of the hundreds of millions of dollars that the federal government spends each year on auto safety research, gun violence research gets pennies. And Stephen Terrett knows all of this. But of all the people I talked to, he was also the most hopeful, which I found kind of hard to understand. What lets you still be optimistic,
看着所有这些因素？你正在尽你最大的努力，你做得相当不错，让我陷入了一些绝望的沼泽。但我恐怕你不会成功。我不会那样做的。我不会那样做的原因之一是因为我了解公共卫生几个世纪以来是如何取得进步的。
looking at all of those factors? You're trying your best and you're doing a fairly good job and making me sink into some swamp of despair. But I'm afraid you're not going to succeed in that. I'm not going to do it. And one of the reasons that I'm not going to do it is because I understand something about how public health has made progress over the centuries.
他指出，在这个国家真正减少吸烟花了50多年时间，尽管现在每年有大约27,000人的生命因安全带和安全气囊等技术而获救，但让人们关注汽车安全也花了数十年时间。公共卫生方面的进步确实需要很长时间。公共卫生领域几乎没有任何例子是有人提出了一个想法，每个人都团结在旗帜下说，这是一个绝妙的主意，让我们立即实施它。这不是它的工作方式。相反，这是一场收集数据、确定我们可以改变什么的斗争。
He points out that it took more than 50 years to really reduce smoking in this country, and even though some 27,000 lives are now saved each year by technologies like seat belts and airbags, it took decades to get people to even pay attention to car safety. Progress in public health just takes a really long time. There's hardly any examples in public health where someone came up with an idea. Everyone rallied around the flag saying, that's a wonderful idea. Let's implement it immediately. That's not how it works. Instead, it's a fight to collect the data, to identify what we can change.
最后，进行许多小的渐进式修改，最终挽救成千上万人的生命。人们倾向于认为汽车本身是保证他们在路上安全的关键因素，但汽车设计只是拼图的一小部分。人们在路边可能撞到的东西的工程设计在道路安全中也起着不那么明显但同样关键的作用。我们有一些很酷的例子可以让汽车更安全。我们通过公共统计数据和汽车广告听到了他们的工作，但是
And finally, to make the many small incremental modifications that eventually save tens of thousands of lives. People tend to think the car itself has the critical factor in keeping them safe on the road, but car design is just one piece of the puzzle. The engineering of things people might crash into on the side of the road plays a less obvious but nonetheless critical role in road safety too. We have some cool examples to make cars safer. And we hear about their work, thanks to public statistics and vehicle advertisements, but
道路安全还有另一个不太明显的维度，涉及车辆经常撞到的基础设施。我和我们的数字总监库尔特·科尔斯特德在这里谈谈等式的这一面。我们倾向于认为支撑路灯、电话线和路标等东西的柱子在设计上是坚固的。我的意思是，它们必须能够抵御自然因素，对吧？
there's another less visible dimension to road safety, which involves the infrastructure that vehicles often crash into. And I'm here with our digital director, Kurt Kohlstedt, to talk a little bit about that side of the equation. We tend to think of posts that support things like streetlights and telephone wires and road signs as being robust by design. I mean, they have to be to stand up to the elements, right?
但有时这些相同的支撑物实际上必须发挥非常不同的功能，即当它们被撞击时，它们必须以正确的方式断裂，这有助于最大限度地减少车辆损坏。所以它们被设计成既要站立和坚固，也要能被撞倒。那么这是如何工作的呢？一种流行的解决方案类型称为滑移底座系统。基本上，不是把整根杆子插进地里，那样在被撞击时会造成很大的损坏，工人们用两块零件组装一根杆子。首先，有一个低矮的柱子，顶部板稍微突出地面。
But sometimes those same supports actually have to serve a really different function, which is they have to break in just the right way when they get hit, which helps minimize vehicle damage. So they're designed to stand up and be sturdy, but also to get knocked down. So how does that work? One popular type of solution is called a slip- base system. Basically, instead of sticking a whole pole into the ground, which could do a lot of damage when it gets hit, workers assemble a pole out of two pieces. First, there's a low post, the top plate that just sticks up slightly above the ground.
然后另一根柱子被连接并用螺栓固定在那个底座上。而上面的那根杆子就是支撑标志的那根。没错。你看到的大部分是上面的那根杆子。这个想法是，当汽车撞击那根上面的杆子时，它会从下面的柱子上断开，从而对车辆及其乘员造成较小的伤害。
And then another post is attached and bolted to that base. And that upper pole is the one that holds the side. Exactly. Most of what you see is that upper pole. And the idea is that when a car hits that upper pole is the one that holds the side. Exactly. Most of what you see is that upper pole. And the idea is that when a car hits that upper post, it will then break away from the lower post and cause less harm to a vehicle and less harm to its occupants.
这也使得碰撞后修复柱子变得容易得多，因为通常可以在刚刚留下的旧底座顶部安装一个新的顶部柱子。对。所以连接螺栓会因为汽车撞击顶部柱子的力量而断裂，
And this also makes fixing a post a lot easier after a collision because often a new top post can just be installed on the top of the old base that just got left behind. Right. So the connecting bolts, they snap from the force of the car hitting the upper post
而底部柱子保持完整。这确实是一个聪明的解决方案。当你想到它时，它实际上非常简单。但你是怎么知道这个的？因为即使你看到了它们，它们，这并不明显。是的，它们无处不在。老实说，我以前从未注意到它们。
and the lower post stays intact. And that's really a clever solution. It's actually pretty simple when you think about it. But how did you even learn about this? Because even though you see them, they, it's not obvious. Yeah, they're everywhere. And I'll be honest, I'd never noticed them before.
让我对它们感兴趣的是这个家伙，我有一个叫汤姆·帕伦特的PI粉丝写信告诉我关于它们的事，然后我开始对它们着迷。我甚至打电话给我身为物理学家的父亲，开始和他一起研究它们，问他关于作用力以及它是如何工作的。但真正吸引我的是这个特定的断裂标志杆，汤姆发了一张照片，而不是像我描述的第一种那样的一对平坦的板，上面的和下面的柱子在某种平坦的交叉点连接，这个例子有倾斜的板。好吧，所以你给我看了这张照片。板是倾斜的。它们是朝向行驶方向的。是的，没错。在这种所谓的倾斜滑移底座系统中，它做了一些非常了不起的事情。所以不是像普通柱子那样只是侧向剪切，柱子的顶部
And what got me interested in them is this the sky and I had a PI fan named Tom Parent wrote in about them and then I started geeking out about them. I even called my dad who's a physicist and started Gicking out with him about them and asking him about the forces and play and how it all worked. But it really hooked me was this one particular Breakaway signpost that Tom said a photo of and And rather than a pair of flat plates, like that first one I described, where the upper and lower posts connect at sort of this flat intersection, this example had angled plates. Okay, so you've shown me the picture of this one. The plates are angled. They're up in the direction of travel. Yes, exactly. And in this so-called incline slip-based system, it does something pretty remarkable. So instead of sharing just sideways, like the normal posts, the top of the
实际上向上翻转并移开。所以倾斜的板将断裂的柱子向上发送，而不是仅仅向前。我们的网站上有这个视频，它显示汽车撞击标志杆。然后整个标志向上翻转并越过汽车，然后落在它后面。如果知道行驶方向，这些效果很好，对吧？即被撞击的方向。例如，沿着道路的右侧。
post actually flips up and out of the way. So the angled plate sends the broken post upward rather than just forward. And we've got a video of this on our website and it shows the car hitting a signpost. And then the whole sign flips up and over the car and then lands behind it. And these can work great if you know the kind of direction of travel, right? The direction from which this thing is going to be impacted. So for example, along the right hand side of a road.
对，对。所以对于单个柱子有平坦和倾斜的滑移底座，但还有很多其他类型，对吧？哦，是的，有很多非常整洁的变化。例如，在一些路边标志上，它们有两根柱子支撑它们，每一侧一根。
Right, right. So they're flat and they're angled slip bases for individual posts, but there are lots of other types too, right? Oh yeah, there's a lot of really neat variations. Like on some roadside signs, for example, they have like two posts supporting them, one on either side.
例如，靠近车道的一根断裂柱可以向上翻转并移开，而另一根柱子实际上支撑着标志，因此车辆可以直接从标志下方通过。哦，所以它甚至没有断裂。只是底部，一半塌陷了。没错，就像它在铰链上一样，它只是向上翻转并移开。只是底部，一半塌陷了。没错。
And one breakaway post, for example, closer to a lane can flip up and out of the way while the other post actually holds up the sign, and therefore the vehicle can just pass like right underneath the sign. Oh, so it doesn't even break away. Just the bottom, the one half kind of collapses. Exactly, like it's on a hinge, and it just kind of flips up and out of the away. It's just the bottom, the one half collapses. Exactly.
它在铰链上，它只是向上翻转并移开。让汽车通过，然后它就保持在原位。电话杆上有一个更大的版本，它们在顶部有铰链，所以它们实际上可以在底部断裂。它们不是直接撞在车上，而是直接摆动开。其他柱子承担了两侧线路的负载。
It's on a hinge and it just flips up and out of the way. Let's the cargo through and then it just stays in place. And then there's a bigger version of this on telephone poles, which have hinges all the way up at the top so they can actually break away at the base. And instead of them just crashing down on the car, they just swing out of the way. And the other posts take up the load of those lines on either side.
所以电话线在柱子断裂后支撑着电话杆的其余部分。这太神奇了。是的，它仍然可能造成损坏，对吧？它仍然可能损坏线路，但它不太可能把整个系统带到你身上，或者让这根木柱子压碎你的车。哇，这太神奇了。一旦你开始寻找它们，你就会开始看到这些断裂系统到处都是
So the telephone lines hold up the rest of the telephone pole once the pole was broken away. That's amazing. Yeah, and it could still do damage, right? It could still hurt the lines, but it's less likely to bring like the whole system down on top of you or to have this like wooden post just crush your car. Wow, that's amazing. And once you start looking for them, you start seeing these breakaway systems just all
到处都是。驱动装置和机制各不相同。有很多不同的特定子类型，但通常是靠近地面的那种连接，以某种形式或方式暴露了它们。哦，那太了不起了。库尔特和我最近还与Vox Media的克里斯托弗·霍弗森合作制作了一个视频，关于通过完全移除标志来改善交通安全。城市设计师称之为共享空间方法，这是一种非常数据驱动但也很复杂且颇具争议的方法。所以你可以查看那个视频，也可以在我们的网站上看到断裂柱的图片和视频。网址是99pi.org。
over the place. And the droids and the mechanisms vary. There's a lot of different specific subtypes, but usually it's that connection near the ground in one form or another that gives them away. Oh, that's remarkable. Kirt and I also recently worked on a video with Christoph Hoverson of Vox Media about improving traffic safety by removing signs entirely. Urban designers call it a shared space approach and it's a very data driven but also complex and pretty controversial. So you can check out that video and also see images and videos of break-way posts in action on our website. It's 99pi.org.
本节目由斯坦·奥尔科恩制作，德莱尼·霍尔编辑，谢丽·福塞夫进行技术制作，肖恩·里亚尔配乐。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，其余工作人员包括艾弗里·肖万、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、泰兰·马扎和我，罗曼·马尔斯。感谢纽约长老会医院、威尔康奈尔医学中心档案馆提供休·德黑文的音频。这个故事来自播客《揭秘》，来自调查报道中心和PRX，如果你想在耳朵里听到更多深入的报道，你真的应该订阅。
This show is produced by Stan Elcorn and edited by Delaney Hall, mixed in tech production by Sheree Fusev, music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director, the rest of staff includes Avery Chauvin, Emmett Fitzgerald, Terran Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. Thanks to the Medical Center Archives of New York Presbyterian, Wild Cornel, for the audio of You to Haven. This story came to us from the podcast Reveal, from the Center for Investigative Reporting and PRX, and if you want more deep reporting in your ears, you should really subscribe
本节目由Stan Elcorn制作，Delaney Hall剪辑，Sheree Fusev负责技术制作与混音，音乐由Sean Rial创作。Katie Mingle担任高级制作人，Kurt Colstead担任数字总监，其他工作人员包括Avery Chauvin、Emmett Fitzgerald、Terran Mazza以及我，Roman Mars。感谢纽约长老会医院威尔康奈尔医学中心档案馆提供《You to Haven》的音频。本报道来自Reveal播客，由调查报道中心和PRX制作，如果你想收听更多深度报道，请务必订阅。
to Reveal. Every week, they're working with investigative journalists around the country and around the world to expose wrongdoing, hold people accountable, and just tell great stories. Like how the town of Kermit, West Virginia ended up with 9 million hydrocodone pills, or what the Pizzagate pedophilia conspiracy theory tells us about Russian trolls. Find Reveal on Radio Public or Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. 99% invisible is a project of KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California.
欢迎收听《Reveal》。他们每周都与全国乃至全球的调查记者合作，揭露不法行为，追究相关责任，并讲述精彩的故事。比如西弗吉尼亚州克米特镇是如何收到900万片氢可酮药片的，或者“披萨门”恋童癖阴谋论向我们揭示了关于俄罗斯网络水军的什么信息。你可以在Radio Public、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的平台上找到《Reveal》。《99% Invisible》是旧金山KALW的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的Radio Row。
We are a part of radio topia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by the night foundation and listeners just like you. You can find 99% of visible and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PIorg, or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But our true home on the internet is 99PI dot org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是PRX旗下Radiotopia的一部分，这是一个汇集了播客界最优秀、最具创新性节目的集合。我们得到了奈特基金会和像你一样的听众的支持。你可以在Facebook上找到《99% Invisible》并参与节目讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars或节目账号@99PIorg，也可以在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上关注我们。但我们在互联网上真正的家是99PI.org。Radiotopia，来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。